so a few of you reached out to me on
discord this week and asked me to help
you
some more with archicad 24 so that's
exactly what we're doing here today
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about arcade 24 and
how we can utilize
a very simple inspirational image this
one in particular
and creating it and replicating it in
arcade 24.
now the image i've selected has come
through from one of you guys on the
discord private message chat
there's a link down below if you want to
join the discord chat there's a few
members on there we're slowly growing it
it's slowly getting more and more
popular
and hopefully we'll build a little
community there where all architects and
designers can collaborate
and help create better designs together
in
one unique space anyway i wanted to show
you exactly how to create this model in
arcad 24
and then take it over to twin motion and
render it out
in less than 30 minutes now that's
always the goal we try to smash out a
tutorial like this in 30 minutes
hopefully we get that in that time frame
if we do it even quicker fantastic if we
take a little bit longer that's okay
hopefully you learn
lots in the process anyway enough of my
face
let's turn around to these screens and
get started with today's tutorial
alright so we've got our inspiration
image open on the left screen here and
we've got our cad 24 being recorded
on the right screen i'm going back to
this
two panel system here which probably
gonna turn into a three panel system
to keep this image in its screen the
whole video so you guys can see how
we're thinking through it and how
replicating it
let me know if you do like this system
more so or if you'd still prefer the
floating head
down below i'm trying to make these
videos a lot more interactive and a lot
more engaging with you all
so that's why i'm thinking that this two
panel system works pretty well
but so far the comments have been
floating ahead i'm gonna test it for a
little bit and if it is still floating
ahead at the end of the day
well we're going back to the traditional
floating head system i chose this image
here sent through by one of you guys on
the discord chat for the very simple
reason
that it features a number of different
elements that we really need to work
through
so as you can see we have very thick
walls that aren't traditionally stored
in arcade 24 from the get-go
we have steps we have a timber feature
screen we have pfc
members running behind we have garden
beds
on the right we have a pond we have the
street we have curbing we have
all sorts of elements so i wanted to
start with the foundations and
start where we start with most videos
and that's by clicking ctrl
seven so control seven will open up your
story settings it lets you enable
all the different heights in the
building in the project that you have
going for me i always like to insert a
story below and call it footings
in this instance i'm actually going to
lower it by
600 instead of by our usual 172 which is
the typical slab thickness including a
footing
i'm going for 600 here because i'm
basically gauging it off a three-step
system and
the actual soil for the tree as well
so a tree of that size would need about
a meter of deep soil
to be able to grow and have the root
systems function properly
i'm not a landscape architect i'm a
regular architect but that's just my
experience with trees
it would depend on the different species
of course but we're just going generic
at the moment
it is sitting inside the ground as well
so 600 is just additional soil and then
you have natural ground level below
but we're calling our footings 600ml in
this instance and
we're probably gonna go and call our
ground floor the top
of that blade wall on the right hand
side which looking at it the man's
probably about 1.8 and you can probably
fit
three if not four of him on the side
so let's call the top of our ground
floor six
meters i don't know what's happening
behind i'm not going to worry about
what's happening behind
we're just focusing on the main
inspiration image so let's click ok
and our story settings have been set up
i'm going to start by creating a generic
mesh of the overall site so we know
we're really working with i think it's a
relatively small site
we're probably not talking any bigger
than 10 by 10
but i'm gonna make it about 20 by 20
to actually be able to model
the street the curbing the grass the
footpath and everything that we see as
well so what i did there is go down to
this mesh tool here on the right hand on
the left hand side of the panel click on
mesh
click once and drag up secondary time i
haven't clicked
but what i can do is press the tab
button which will let us
change the dimensions manually so i'm
going to type in 20 000
press tab again and then type in 20 000
once more so now we have our foundations
of our
overall site that we're going to be
playing with i don't want to really
have to worry about the corners of the
street and everything so i'm actually
going to just utilize the inside of this
site
by holding alt i can activate my
eyedropper tool which lets me replicate
the settings of anything that i click on
so i'm going to once again click on that
mesh tool and simply create a 10
by 10 square by repeating the same steps
we talked about
i'm going to click on this internal
square once press ctrl
d and select the bottom node i'm going
to move it to one corner
press ctrl d again click on the top node
move it to the opposite side so 14 142
if we half that
that's about 7071.
so i'm just going to type in 7071 on a
45 degree angle
centers that almost perfectly in the
center of that shape
now this shape we've created here is
going to be our main foundation of the
building
and we're going to slowly work our way
in towards that
if you're not really concerned about any
of the site context and layout how we're
going to create that you can
skip ahead in the timeline you know
somewhere down there
i will put the markers in so you can
jump ahead but we're going to focus on
our road we're going to focus on our
curb
and our landscaping just quickly before
we move into that section so roads are
anywhere from 6 to 12 to 18 meters wide
depending on the roads themselves
this one's probably not much wider than
six meters so what i'm going to do is
click on one of the
outskirts of these perimeters click on
it once
click on offset all edges i don't want
offset edge i want offset
all edges and then i'm going to tap the
control key again
now you can see that we're offsetting
more and more and more as we move in
and we only have five meters to our
building that we're planning on
designing
we probably need three meters for the
landscaping and garden
etc if not more we can call it five so
instead of going inwards i'm actually
going to go outwards
six meters so now we have an even larger
square than we traditionally started
with if i click
m to open up my measure tool i can click
once
to just double check that is six meters
and click again to keep
measuring in different directions but we
don't need to so escape key will get you
out of that one if i open up the
settings of
this mesh section here i can see that
this is created as grass i don't want
that to be grass
let's just change that to concrete so if
you type in c-o-n
it'll quickly jump to some sort of
concrete material we'll go concrete
light 23
for the purposes of this and i'll make
it all concrete light
and override all settings by linking it
together so we click ok
that's completed i can now go ahead and
start messing
with the curbing and the grass itself
so if we do the same thing and open up
the settings we can come up to the
dialog box or we can click ctrl t
to open up those settings for that
internal square which we're going to be
using as our grass
it's already annotated as grass but what
i want to do is change
the edging of it to concrete as well so
i'm going to go into this and change it
to a different sort of concrete i'm just
going to click concrete 2
that'll make sense in twin motion when
we get there because it's all about
material color matching
i'm also going to increase this by 100
millimeters
to create that curbing there itself it's
a generic way to create a curb we can go
and model that in a lot more detail but
it looks like it's just a
simple square flush curve so we're just
clicking ok
and we've created partial areas of our
site
if i go show in 3d in this tab up here
we'll see that we've started to create
our site so we have our road
we have our very simple very very simple
curbing along the edge
and we have our grass on top now if i go
back in
to this ground floor plan and look at
this curbing that we've created
comparing it to what we have in 3d it's
not very realistic we don't really have
any depth to it
so what i want to do is actually click
on one of the edges
offset all edges control and i'm going
to go about 150 mil
so you'll see we've created a secondary
mesh
inside i want to click on the outside
one click on any of the corners
select my minus hold space
and then click once more so now i'm
going to open up the settings again by
clicking ctrl
t and change this all to concrete2
so now i have a curb in full 3d so if we
come back to our 3d
you'll see that we actually have a full
curve
rather than what we were having before
so now we're slowly getting
to understand our context and slowly
starting to create our shapes that we
need
if i come back with my ground floor plan
i know we're walking into the building
about here
so what i'm going to do is select the
grassed area that we've created
click again on one of those corners
and click on the interior square
now that basically just chops out the
middle of the building as much as we can
very quickly by holding space and
clicking on that shape
and now i'm going to continue creating
the rest of the environment so we have a
little footpath coming in here
so if i click on one of these corners
again get the
subtract tool come up to the top and use
a rectangle
geometry i can create a footpath of
approximately three meters i believe
that would be more than enough
and then what i can do is select our
kerbing come across to our
axe tool split it is also the control
and forward slash key if you want a
shortcut for it
but all we have to do is click on that
little axe and
click on that line there holding shift
to make sure
we aren't locking and moving in any
direction except
perfectly perpendicular down and
clicking in the direction we want to
keep our selection so if i click cut
you'll see it's cut
all the way through that axe which is
fine because i'm not really worried
about the back end of this building as
we have this highlighted i want to click
again on one of these edges
and then i want to select the single
offset edge tool
and just drag that back to the start of
the footpath
i want to also do the same thing on both
sides here to create a kerb
wrapping back into this building so what
i'm going to simply do
is click the plus sign instead of the
minus sign this time
and move it up press tab go 150
gives us our new curbing do the same on
this side going all the way up
150 and if we check out our 3d
there it is over this side we've started
to model our curbing we've started to
model our footpath
now it looks like this section of the
footpath is a little bit higher than the
actual road level
so what we can do is simply click on one
of these edges
click the subtract tool and draw a
square
over that we can then hold alt and
highlight our footpath that we used
before holding space
and clicking again we can rapidly create
a new
section so i can increase that by
opening ctrl t going just 50 ml for the
time being
and lifting that 50 ml off the ground
now you see this is flickering
constantly and really annoying for this
very simple fact that we have multiple
elements overlaid
so if we come back into our ground floor
plan click on
the overall square you'll see that it's
overlaying
and falling and failing because of this
so we can simply
click the edge hold space and get rid of
that secondary one
so now we don't have anything
overlapping for our
main building shape if i click on this
mesh
click ctrl t again highlight all of
those override surface models and
change that to let's say concrete
10 in this instance and i also want to
lift it up 600 millimeters because
that's going to be the basis of our
design
clicking ok we're starting to see it all
come together so there's only a couple
elements left this design i think
there's a small footpath wrapping around
the building
and another footpath wrapping to the
right and then we have
our garden kind of pond planter on the
right hand side as well
so before we start going into our actual
building i'm going to quickly finish off
the edge of this context here so if we
say we have a footpath that wraps around
the entire building what we'll do is
actually
select our curbing as best as we can
tricky if you can never select the right
one that you're looking for
just hover over what you're looking for
and tab your way through it
so tab will allow you to select
different elements quickly
we're gonna select the edge move that
back
one meter and then we're gonna click one
of the edges select the additional tool
hold shift running the line with the
edge of our building context
and tab down twice to this 1000 meter
instead of going upwards we actually
want to go in the opposite direction so
we can
actually type minus 150 which creates
our curbing
internally we also want to extend this
an additional meter
and then repeat the same process on this
side here
so there we have it minus 150 we've
created a new curve that wraps all the
way around we can then
quickly click on some of these edges
here
drag out the mesh that we've created
click on the new mesh
and if we click the simple geometric
method
we can click a few times to create
our footpath on the left hand side
if you do make a mistake like that you
can click backspace to come out of it
and then double click to finish no
matter where you are in the project
if we come back to our show all in 3d we
can see we've created that
recessed footpath with the kerbing
wrapping around and all we have to do is
create the same effect
on the right hand side so the same
process very simple
select the curve drag one meter down
click one of the nodes
make sure the plus is selected make sure
the rectangular
geometry is selected drag it all the way
across
and tab 150. now we have to do
is remove this section of the grass
and increase this section of the
footpath by repeating the same process
as we did a moment ago
now coming back into 3d you'll see that
we've created that new footpath we have
some of our grass overlapping our curve
and hence the flickering
we can edit this in 3d if we like so
just simply clicking that
coming over to our offset edge and
retracting it across
and we've created our new path going
that way i would assume there'd be some
sort of curbing on this side as well
because we have some sort of pond
so what i'll do is again click on a node
make sure that plus sign is selected
come across here let's go 150 and
i'm going to cut this
section again and drag that
off setting it back 150. so what we've
done is actually split this mesh
from this mesh so if i open up the
settings by clicking command t
highlighting all of these override
surfaces and typing in
water i can make it water wavy pond
and now we have some sort of pond on the
right hand side
i'm going to use the same footpath to
create the foundation of this tree
in the center of this pond over here so
i'll just hold the alt
key select that and draw
a one meter by one meter square it
wouldn't be a meter biometer in this
image but
i think that is a more realistic planter
size
and then what i'll do is very similar to
how we started the project
clicking on offset all edges clicking
the control key
and going 150 and then selecting our
outside box
going the minus holding space clicking
again
to be able to create some sort of
curbing inside now i'm holding shift and
the
scroll wheel of the mouse to be able to
fly a little bit more freely
i'm going to open up the settings of
those two and lift that
to about 200. now we don't need the
center one whatsoever
but for visual effects we'll go back
here
we'll change that to earth brown and
we'll also click control d to lower that
by 50 millimeters so our tree can sit in
that planter in the middle of the pond
there so now the overall context of the
actual site is completed
it would be a car wrapping around here
on the left hand side
this would be a lot narrower than what
we've actually created so
we can cut that back in if we want to
but we don't really have to
and we'd have some sort of landscaping
on the right hand side as well however
that's the general context completed
which means we can move
on to the building elements themselves
now the building elements themselves
seem relatively simple but there's some
complex tricks in here that i wanted to
teach you guys today
and that's why out of all the images i
selected this one so if we come back
into our ground floor plan
we're going to be utilizing this space
here in the center as our building
foundation we can see that the
main concrete wall on the right hand
side which is rendered pure white
is quite thick and quite large i'd call
that almost a
500 mil thick wall which could be a
series of different walls wrapped around
made out of timber made out of concrete
could be
constructed in a magnitude of different
ways but let's
envision that it's potentially just one
solid 500ml concrete wall now to create
that there's a number of ways we can do
it the easy way
clicking on wall tool clicking on a wall
and then
changing the structure to a basic
composition and changing it to 500
millimeters
or we can do it the more complex way now
i haven't shown you this on my channel
yet so i wanted to show you the more
complex way the harder way is to go into
composites
open up your composites panel and it
will open up all the different wall
types that archicad has available to you
right now
it doesn't really matter what one we
select for the purpose of this but i'm
just going to select
a concrete suspended 250 ml suspended
concrete plus timber finish
and then i'm going to click new it's
going to open up a secondary dialog box
and i'm going to call it 500 millimeter
concrete and click ok now it's
divided into different skins different
colors and different details depending
on how you actually document but for the
purposes of this wall and this
construction
we really need it to be a very simple
concrete wall so we're going to remove
the skin of the timber layer we're going
to remove the skin of the dip rock
and we're going to change that to 500
millimeters now before we click ok we
have to make sure that we have our wall
selected and deselect our floor we don't
want that as a floor composite we want
it as a wall composite
and now we can click ok and actually
find it
in our basic wall structure so it would
be one of the first ones most likely
because
the rest are actually lettered and our
first one started with a number so
500 millimeter concrete wall if we
start drawing that we can see it's a
very thick
very chunky wall but that's exactly what
we wanted
so we have our first concrete mass wall
here
and we have our secondary concrete mass
wall
here which actually looks like it comes
through that footpath and makes that
footpath completely redundant
and a waste of time drawing but hey
we're replicating somebody else's design
and
that's all part of the experience right
so now we've drawn our two
blade concrete walls and if we come back
into 3d
we'll see they're absolutely gigantic
which is perfect because that's what we
want i want to offset
this edge here back in line with this
concrete wall so we don't have that
flickering
effect and i'm going to change the
materiality of these
so if i come into this wall ctrl t to
open up the settings i'm going to
overwrite
all the layers and i'm just going to
pick
extraco rough white it doesn't really
matter it's just going to be a white
concrete panel and i'm going to open up
the settings
of this section of the wall too do the
exact same
and find a different concrete material
now we've used
concrete light 23 for the road but
hopefully it should be okay
to use for this one as well if not we'll
come in later and change it again in
twin motion
so now we have those two massive blade
walls coming out that are striking
and really really nice but we need some
stairs to get up that
there's a number of ways we can create
our stairs we can click on this
and we can remove about 600 ml of that
so 600 millimeters of that removed
maybe let's even go to 900 millimeters
because there's three steps and then
what we're going to do is create
three large concrete steps so i'm going
to hold alt clicking on that
and pressing once with my square
selected tab
300 millimeters creating my first step
i'm going to click on that
control d click on one corner plus with
control
and then repeat that step to get our
third step so now if we open up our 3d
nothing's really changed but you'll see
that if we click
quickly we'll see three different steps
now what i didn't realize is the third
step is
actually the foundation so we can delete
that third step
click on the edge extend that back 300
millimeters
select both of these steps by holding
the shift key
pressing ctrl d and moving that first
one down
200 millimeters and moving that second
one down by repeating that same step
another 200 millimeters and there we
have it we have our three steps created
but we have flickering here so
i'm going to select that main slab click
on our axe tool
and split that slab entirely so i can
drag that across
in line with that new wall that we've
created
so that flickering ceases and desists so
it appears like this section
here is more so little square tiles
so again what i'll do is open up pick
some tiles
click ok and deal with that in a
materiality section
in twin motion coming back into our
ground floor plan
we noticed that there is a very large
opening on this right hand side so you
can use the opening tool but i prefer to
use
the wall opening so if i go into door
click on the door settings
and type in simple it'll open up the
simple
door opening object and i want to create
that as
three meters tall and potentially i'm
unsure of the width for now so i'm going
to leave that as
off i'm going to select one side over
here
it falls in line with that back wall
that runs along the whole way and then
wraps up the top
so i'll run that all the way to the edge
of that wall and i'll extend that
by clicking one of these nodes making
sure i
move node and i'll probably align it
with the edge of that
for simply the fact that it's some sort
of indicator in this project now if we
come back into 3d we'll see
it's opened up it's broken that section
and it looks really nice
but it isn't three meters from the top
of this wall it's three meters from the
bottom of the ground
so to make sure that this is actually
sitting on top of this i'm just going to
select the corner
anywhere that i know a corner is click
control
d and then move that up in the project
by holding
shift and clicking in line with the edge
of
the slab we've created so now we have
this beautiful slab here we have the
opening
on the side and we can start creating
our back wall
it looks like the back wall is the same
material as this wall so what i'll do
is hold the alt key to create to
replicate that one
and i will run one massive wall
from here to here i'll stop there and
then i'll start a secondary wall here
because they're two different heights
now this wall
does actually run underneath it
so what i'll do is click control
d to be able to move that wall under
that wall
that we just drew that opening for so
coming back into our 3d we'll see our
new wall has been constructed i can
click on
this secondary wall that we made
clicking on one of the nodes and
moving to stretch height coming to the
bottom and lining that
underneath just like we see in the
picture from that angle that we have
replicated in the photo
it would be something similar to this
where i don't actually unfortunately see
what's happening above or over here
but i'm just going to assume that
there's nothing here because we can't
see it we're just focusing on the front
of the building itself now the rest of
this project is actually relatively
simple it's mainly walls it's mainly
pfcs
and it's a repetition of timber we'll
get our uap
beam 24 now i usually call this a pfc
which is a parallel flange
channel but that's what the standard is
in archicad 24 so we're just going to go
with it for now we'll probably need a
much
larger beam on the bottom and top like
it's replicated
in this image but all they give us is
300 we can actually define a custom
size and change these bits and pieces
around if we want to
so i think that's probably a lot bigger
it's probably about 500 which will make
that about 150
with a 12 mil actual thickness
and the rest of the items don't actually
matter too much
so i'll change the object as well
because objects are quite important so
if we come into beams
beams exterior and click ok we can start
by creating our first beam that beam
appear appears to wrap
in line with the edge of the concrete
slab so what i'll do is click control d
on one of the nodes move it to the end
click on the center node now to be able
to drag it
all the way across now because i do want
it to match at a perfect 45 degree angle
i'll click
one of these nodes hold the shift key
wrap that back to 45 degrees
do the same for that section and then
re-select the center node so i can move
it back i'm going to move it back a
little bit too far
so i can perfectly align it with the
edge here
now the simplest way without having to
recreate that 45 degrees and worrying
about is it perfect or not
if we hold ctrl and press m we will get
our mirror
tool and then we can click our control
button again to get the plus sign
so clicking on one node and then
realigning it to the second node
rapidly creates our secondary pfc i can
click on that
once more to extend it to the end so now
if i just quickly
check that these are about one meter off
the ground so we can see them
clicking okay going back into our 3d
we'll now see our big beams
right here on the ring because they are
black pfcs in this image clicking okay
we've created our first pfc i'm going to
then click ctrl
d clicking control again to duplicate it
holding the shift key to move it in a
vertical direction
and i'm gonna move that 4200 millimeters
so that gives us a little bit off the
top for our structural
integrity and i'm going to create one
more dropping it in the middle
so 2100 and then i'm going to change it
to en standards and i'm just going to
make it a 100 beam
and then i'm going to lift it another
500 millimeters because it isn't
perfectly in the center
in this image on the left that we're
using as inspiration
okay so now we've got our pfcs created
we've got most of our buildings modeled
we just need that timber screening to
happen so if we come back into our
ground floor plan go to our column tool
open the column settings we can start
replicating our columns i think the
timber battens in this case would be
unequal they would be about 50
millimeters wide
and they would potentially be about 75
millimeters
deep so i'll change that to 75 deep 50mm
wide and i'll also override to some sort
of
timber material now the structure for
the purposes of this isn't too important
but if we didn't want to change it we'd
change it to some sort of timber so
just be timber stud or actually it'll be
a timber batten it's nothing important
it's non-structural
and we click ok coming down to the edge
i want to select my very first one
and i'm going to place that right
against hard against
this concrete and then drag it 50
millimeters across
i don't like the cross hairs in this so
i'm going to open up the settings again
by clicking ctrl
t go to the floor plan and then scroll
down
to floor plan symbol cross heads i'm
just going to change it to plane
so we don't have a million crosshairs
now so we don't have to go through and
create these one by one
we can simply click on one of these
nodes go multiply
go to our spread input the spacing of
100
click ok click on one of the nodes and
drag it all the way across till we reach
the end
now it looks like we aren't reaching the
end perfectly it's a bit of an odd
spacing so i'm going to click here
without clicking anything i'm going to
go back to the original one holding
shift
click on it again and then i'm going to
click control g
that simply groups them all together so
we don't have to go back and click them
one by one now i've got
approximately 50 ml on this side 50 ml
on the other side which i think
is more than acceptable in this case i'm
going to click alt
g to ungroup the selection click
control d and then control again to
duplicate
one more to the edge i'm going to click
control e
to open up the protractor tool and
rotate it 90 degrees
around the edge of this pfc and then
once more control d
moving across so just like we replicated
these we're going to do the same thing
going into our multiply settings
clicking ok
and dragging it all the way to the edge
of this pfc
so as you can see another one ends at
50mm so we'll just click it there
go all the way back to our first
original click it
ctrl g and group okay so now we can take
a look in 3d to see
how far we've come along and we've
created something that's looking quite
similar however we need to increase the
height of these to stop
just in line with the edge of this slab
instead of going all the way to the
ground so by clicking on one we'll see
we aren't grouped anymore so alt g
reactivates our grouping
clicking on that one again we'll have to
ungroup this to be able to do our next
step so alt
g once more selecting the bottom and
then
clicking our stretch height again if we
drag that up to the edge of the bottom
of that
slab that's 5 2 in the purposes of this
and it's also going 6 meters but it
looks like it stops perfectly in line
with the edge of the top of the pfc so
i'm going to click on one of the top
again
and change the height down in line with
the pfc so there we go it's
automatically changed all of them we
don't have to go through one by one
it's giving us that feature timber
screen through to that timber and we're
starting to basically see our finished
product
if we also come into our ground floor
plan the last thing we want to change
is clicking on this center square here
clicking one of the nodes going minus
and
introducing some sort of
earth texture there so i'll cut out a
big square i'll hold
alt i'll hold space and click once more
go back into our 3d we'll see
that i've created a big earth patch so
i'm going to click on that earth
ctrl d drag it up at the top ctrl d back
down 50 millimeters for that nice
giant tree now if you can't tell already
i'm a little bit sick i'm a little bit
under the weather
but i promise you guys a video every
monday so i'd really appreciate it if
you subscribe to this channel for the
simple fact that i'm very committed and
there we have it guys that is basically
the construction that we can see in
front of us in this example image
it is basically to the best of our
ability without seeing
more of these images so what we're
actually going to do now is go
twin motion 2022 or twin motion 2020
direct link and let that load we have a
few little things going on
nothing too major my settings on ultra
low so if i go into preferences
quality will go back up to high just so
we have a bit more information
to play with and understand and then
we're going to start
manipulating this actual environment so
if we come down to the bottom
and go into settings we're going to go
to local location first
and we're going to change our location
to perth because that's where i am at
the moment now winter always provides
some really nice shadows but it looks
like this is more of a nighttime render
in the opposite direction so if we
change our north point
to somewhere on the right hand side of
the page we can see most of our shadows
probably from the moon over on that side
so we're actually going to reduce this
down
to probably nine o'clock at night time
so we can start seeing some of our
night nighttime renders come through
we're going to adjust there it is if i
zoom back out a little bit and look up
the moon is
just there it's definitely too high
but that's okay we don't really need to
see it too much
it doesn't matter how much i drop these
months it's not going to drop any lower
in the sky
unfortunately so that's roughly where we
have our project
at the moment it's a nighttime render
we're going to change the background to
just some sort of countryside
it doesn't matter we're going to fill it
with trees and then if we go back into
our settings we can change our weather
there's no clouds in the sky there's
just a couple little stars which is
really nice we don't have to change
any of that that's more than likely
exactly what we want to see
so we're going to start by introducing
some lighting into this project going
lights
going neon light and clicking along
the bottom here which is what we see so
if i click on that i'm going to reduce
that to about
10 and i'm going to reduce that to about
five
six six and a half meters roughly
clicking tab i can extend that to where
i need it to go
exactly and position my neon light
there so we have one neon light on that
side i'm gonna hold
shift and drag one of these to create a
copy
i want an instance because i want it to
be exactly the same rotate that
90 degrees and then position that on
this side
of the building as well so we have our
neon lights underneath
there we need a three little spotlights
on this side
so if i create a little spotlight here
rotate that 90 degrees
and reduce the intensity to 10. we can
see we have
one little spotlight here two more on
this side
so one copy here drag that
oop drag that to where it needs to be
one more copy
at the end okay i'm going to select all
three of these
drag them across the other side click ok
and rotate them 180 degrees
so they face the other way it looks like
we have a lot of up lighting
in here on this project here so let's
start by going back and introducing
a large tree in this area so we can
actually focus
our lighting on it i think maybe a
japanese walnut would look nice in this
render
so that's quite large quite similar to
what we have in the actual
inspiration image and then we're going
to go back in to
our lighting and start introducing some
more spotlights around the tree
so clicking one rotating that 90 degrees
rotating that another 45 degrees and
then
angling it towards our tree and reducing
the intensity to about 20 in this
situation i'm going to replicate a few
more of those around the tree
by just quickly holding shift and
dragging across
so creating an instance going okay drag
that
this way so it points at the tree and
i'll do the same
for these two on the other side so now
we have our tree illuminated it looks
like
the back wall has a little bit of iv
growing onto it as well so come into
vegetation we go into miscellaneous
clicking on falling iv clicking
sporadically a few times
changing the iv to make sure we get
different
patterns different textures so it
doesn't look like
one very large blob and then introducing
another light into that back source
it does look like that light is a bit
more of a
directional light than anything else but
i'll put one more spotlight at
that there so if i change that to 20 and
i increase the angle of the light that
it throws i might have to increase that
to about 50
and drag it back a little bit so it
throws it more at the wall
there we go now we have our light source
on that back wall
if we come back out we can see we have
our tree illuminated
we have our shrubs illuminated in the
background
we are missing the one illuminating led
neon light here so if i create another
strip light
rotate that 90 degrees and repeat a very
similar process we did to the
bottom of the building dropping the
intensity down to about 10
and reducing that length to about five i
can position it perfectly and we have an
led strip light on that section
so if we continue to find our project
center which is
replicating this image here it is
quite similar to that location there but
we have to introduce a lot more texture
so if we go back into our material we
can use this magazines library so if i
go into surfaces
concrete cast in situ download this cast
in situ concrete
and apply it to the left blade wall
we'll see that it quickly creates a in
situ concrete wall
which probably needs to be either larger
or smaller it's quite hard to tell
because it's so
dark if we leave it at one and download
this
shutter concrete wall and attempt this
texture on this left blade
wall so if i use it on this left blade
wall it's also going to use it on the
road unfortunately but
that's okay because the road isn't that
important in this project
fly around to see what the texture is
that's probably about right i'm going to
go more
rotate the texture 90 degrees and i'm
going to scale that up to about
two maybe four four is probably an
appropriate size
back all the way go to materials go to
concrete
and i'm just going to make that a base
concrete texture
so it is nice white pure and crisp
i'm also going to quickly attempt this
concrete slabs on this side
because it looks a little bit lighter
and a little bit grayer so i'm going to
increase that too
i don't like that at all so let's undo
that by clicking
ctrl z and coming back to our original
image
now this image is still way too dark
because it is night time obviously so
i'm going to go into
settings i'm going to go into the
lighting and i'm going to start playing
around with these settings to make it a
little bit nicer
if i increase the exposure to 0.5
and go to the individual settings i can
increase the star intensity
to make the stars twink a little bit
more and i can also increase the moon
intensity
so if we bring the moon intensity up to
two and increase the ambient up to one
we can begin to see our image a little
bit better i think this final image will
have to be imported into lightroom i'll
show you exactly how to do that at the
end of this tutorial
to really get the most out of this image
but now if we go back into our
vegetation
create some trees let's pick the
japanese
white light and i'm just going to zoom
all the way up to the top
and click quickly around the perimeter
of our project
to create some japanese large trees
around i'm also gonna
throw in some japanese walnuts at the
front
to create some diversity in this texture
and then fly back down to the bottom
to start modeling out grass if i click
in
to the context go vegetation paint come
back up to the top
go brushes go flowers and grass
click lawn and drag the lawn down the
bottom i can increase
my density to 100 percent i can click on
my brush and decrease that to one
because it is a very small area and then
slowly paint all of this in so if i
click
and hold and start creating some grass
you'll see that i'm creating a much
nicer grass texture here than what's
there originally
i'll quickly paint this all in and jump
back to you guys at the end
okay so now i've painted in all my grass
as you can see
it's coming out the edges and it'll show
up in the actual render a lot better
finally we want to insert our water here
so if we come back into our materials
scroll all the way down to water and we
can
insert some sort of a pond maybe pull
two in this instance
is probably a nicest i'll increase the
color
to a little bit lighter and i'll also
introduce a small tree on
this island here so i'll select the
english u for the simple fact that it is
one of the most intricate trees
as a small tree so i'll reduce that all
the way to the smallest
even though that would definitely not be
the tree that would be there considering
the size it grows to
and then zoom back out to find
our overall design the last thing that
we have to introduce now is a car
into the project so simply going into
vehicles cars
it seems like some sort of hatchback so
we will select a hatchback that one
looks good
rotate 90 degrees 180 and change the
color
to white now if we come across to our
media click
image we can create our first image and
we can try and actually
find the correct positioning for it now
if we go into more we can also adjust
the camera settings
if we want it a little bit wider if we
want it a bit more close up it's
completely up to us
74 is usually the frame i like because
it gives you that most realistic
feel and then i'm just going to play
around with it till i
see what i want to see i think i like
that image the most so i'm going to
refresh that i'm going to go into more
i'm going to go into
format and i'm going to change this
format to custom
so what the custom output actually needs
to be
i want that to be two thousand by two
and a half thousand
which is more of an instagram format
which is what we've got going on here
now if we go back into our format and
our image we're starting to see that
moon in the background
we're starting to see a little bit more
of what we originally planned
but the camera settings are a little bit
wrong so what we're going to do is zoom
into about a 50 mil
prime lens and take that depth of field
off
and because we have to zoom out further
i'm actually going to manipulate
the inbuilt mesh of twin motion
to be able to zoom out as far as i need
to to be able to
best create this image here
so i think that is probably best image
we need to create
and finally i'm going to insert one
human on
the right hand side walking up the
stairs it can be a
cut out it can be a posed human it can
be absolutely anything
i like the pose humans because they seem
a little bit more
realistic at the end of the day when you
export something so i'll put this lady
in
with her shopping bags and come back to
our
image here and there we go we have our
final image ready to export
now all we have to do is actually extend
that to full screen go to the export
button
go to image select one and click
the export button okay so now we have
our image open in adobe lightroom
and i'm just going to simply apply one
of my presets they are available
download in the link description if you
want to check them out
so if we scroll through them we can see
a different variation of styles and
and color qualities in this image here
i think for this one personally
something like a spring external would
work quite well
but just adjusting a few more of these
sliders so increasing
a few extra elements to be able to
create more sense
in the actual building here lowering the
black so we see a little bit more
and just painting out that road ever so
slightly so
we don't actually see the road and our
eyes are focused on the building
there we have it that is the completed
image the completed render from start to
finish
using an image that we found as
inspiration and creating something from
absolutely nothing anyway that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below we're almost
at 10 000 subscribers
so thank you for being a part of this
community and like always
i'll see you next monday